I know another diva Britney Spears
wrapped up her cincy residency on New
Year's Eve now her final show set at
Vegas box office record making 1.2
million pretty chillin Vegas now that
success a major factor in her ex Kevin
Federline's new request for more child
support his Federline now demanding
three times the $20,000 a month he
currently gets through Spears that would
be 60 grand
two months ago Britt's ex asked her team
for at least 40 grand
but in just filed court documents he
doesn't seek a specific increase just an
upward modification and $350,000 in
legal fees
his attorney Marc Vincent Kaplan tells
ET there's no other option for us but to
go to court
Rick before she raked in over 135
million dollars during her entire Vegas
run and could pull in 30 million more on
her piece of meat or kick it off in July
there's cash to be happy if you're
living in a mansion you don't want your
kids shouldn't be living in a shack
exactly k-fed salary approximately three
thousand dollars a month as a DJ he
claims that's less than 1% of Spears's
estimated annual income took the time
out to like help my kids grow up the
right way he has full custody of their
boys but Britt's been posting up a storm
hanging with Sean Preston and Jaden
Brittany and her man of the year Sam
istari are working out together gearing
up for her tour and responds to K feds
demands a source close to Spears tells
ET Britney making more money doesn't
change the needs of the boys despite the
drama Kevin says his relationship with
Brit is fine well cool I mean we're
cordial you know we talk that's good to
hear you let the lawyers do all the
dirty work
alright yeah I'll write a court hearing
is set for August 1st and by the way
Britney's concert dates they're gonna
stretch right into September
[Music]